as an economist i've long been in favor
of
getting countries to deal with their
massive imbalances
which have led to
basically one crisis every three years
since the 1980s and specifically that
means that countries that save too much
need to
plow their savings back into supporting
their domestic economy and classic
example that is china
and countries that save too little
need to start saving again and live
within their means and a classic example
of that
is the united states an unbalanced world
is a world that is ripe for crisis there
are many imbalances in in the world
today the two largest
uh are the um the surplus saving of
china and the deficit saving
of the united states
but you know countries like japan
in germany the oil producers
they also save too much and they need to
plow back their savings into supporting
internal
private consumption and of course the
deficit savers
in the south of europe notably
spain
greece portugal and italy
need to
pull back their domestic spending
and start to rebuild their savings to
get out of the crises
they're in we've harbored the mistaken
belief in my opinion
that
unbalanced
growth is sustainable growth and i think
the crises of the last
few decades especially the last few
years
have drawn that complacency into serious
question
you